Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool
hello YouTube now I thought it was
finally time for me to talk about
changes I've been you know talking about
this for a while now
yeah I've been talking about it for a
while and like I said I didn't really
know what what are you doing don't right
now okay
it's not that it's not a good time
sorry about hard just a little Dehradun
work anyway basically please just get
out of my head
please it's not how many times do I have
to tell you I'm not that Charlie I'm not
a bloody eunuch all right so if you load
for a minute
can I go
okay I'll just cut that out okay yeah um
yeah so basically once it really was
[Music]
I didn't just say that where are you
going I took my friggin spleen